.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Beschwingte Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Möchten Sie einen Gratispullover?
Wir verschenken ihn.
Christian Zeyer -
ein Mann im Dilemma:
zwischen profitorientierter
Wirtschaft und Klima-Aktivisten,
die den Kapitalismus
am liebsten abschaffen würden.
(Frau) Gratis zum Mitnehmen.
Habt ihr das Gefühl,
dass eure Botschaft verstanden wird?
Ich hoffe es.
Christian Zeyer:
Chef des klimabewussten
Wirtschaftsverbands Swisscleantech.
Was für ein Bild fällt Ihnen ein,
wenn Sie Ihre Rolle beschreiben?
Hm, ähm ...
Ja ...
* Er lacht. *
Manchmal wie Sisyphos.
Er rollt den Stein hinauf.
Dann fällt er wieder runter
und man muss wieder unten beginnen.
* Tröpfelnde Klänge *
Das ist ein typisches Beispiel, das
zeigt, dass Umwelt keinen Preis hat.
Schaut man dieses T-Shirt an ...
Von der Herstellung bis hierher
wurde überall Energie verbraucht.
Z.B. Kohlestrom in China,
die Fabrikation ist in China.
In der Textilfabrik evtl. Dampf,
hergestellt aus Kohle.
Das gibt CO2-Emissionen -
und die kosten im Moment nichts.
Was müsste geändert werden?
Idealerweise hätte CO2
auf der ganzen Welt einen Preis.
Wer CO2 ausstösst ...
Wer Erdöl verbraucht, wer Kohle
verbraucht und damit CO2 produziert,
müsste dafür bezahlen.
Eine weltweite CO2-Abgabe -
noch völlig undenkbar.
Das Thema Mode und Klima
sowieso unbeliebt.
Billigkleiderläden
wollen nichts dazu sagen.
Und auch der Chef
des Warenhauses Loeb
hat nicht wirklich auf meine Frage
nach einer CO2-Steuer gewartet.
Grundsätzlich
sind wir gegen Abgaben.
Ich denke ...
Noch mehr Abgaben würden den
Detailhandel unheimlich belasten.
Wie soll das Klimaziel
erreicht werden?
Kein Öl, keine Kohle und kein Gas
bis 2050? Das ist auch verbindlich.
Das beantworte ich nicht.
Da kann ich nur verlieren.
Das ist ein klassisches Gespräch,
das ich mit einem CEO führe.
Ich begreife,
dass ein CEO grundsätzlich sagt:
"Ich will gar nichts."
Irgendetwas zu verändern,
ist primär einmal schwierig.
Das ist logisch.
Sie sind bad news für CEOs, weil Sie
ihnen Regel aufoktroyieren wollen
Man kann sich fragen,
was noch schlechtere News wären.
Das wissen wir beide.- Absolut.
- Wir müssen eine Lösung finden,
sonst haben wir langfristig
kein Businessmodell.
Sein Job - ein Schachspiel.
Firmen seien
strategisch wichtige Figuren.
Die Dame im Spiel aber
sei die Politik.
Christian Zeyer will ein Gesetz,
das Firmen und Bürger zwingt,
ihr Verhalten zu ändern:
das revidierte CO2-Gesetz.
Kommt es durch, werden Benzin,
Heizöl und das Fliegen teurer.
Es ist Dezember. Die erste Session
nach dem grünen Wahltsunami.
Die Herausforderungen
sind noch immer dieselben.
Sie sind nicht euphorisch?
- Nein.
Das CO2-Gesetz
wird erst im Frühling verhandelt.
Er will aber heute schon
bei den neuen Parlamentsmitgliedern
dafür lobbyieren.
Und da kommt sein Kontaktmann:
Stefan Müller-Altermatt,
CVP-Nationalrat.
Christian.
- Hallo, Stefan. Vielen Dank.
Hast du einen Badge?
- Jawohl, ich kann losgehen.
Gehen wir rechts oder links rauf?
- Links. Dort, wo es Kaffee gibt.
* Beide lachen. *
Du hast gesagt,
du würdest Frau Z'graggen rausholen.
Ah, Heidi. Genau.
Wartest du hier?
- Ich warte doch ...
Warten auf Heidi Z'graggen,
vormals CVP-Regierungsrätin,
jetzt im Ständerat.
Sie sind bekannt aus Funk und
Fernsehen und mich kennt man nicht.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen gehen?
- Jawohl, genau.
Also Lobbying.
- Ja, natürlich. Klar.
Das ist wichtig.
Beziehungspflege ist wichtig.
Machen Sie das gern?
Es ist eine spannende Sache,
neue Leute kennenzulernen.
Es braucht auch Überwindung,
unbekannte Leute
einfach so anzuquatschen.
Liegt Ihnen das Anquatschen?
Sie beginnen erst
und haben noch Appell.
Heidi kommt sicher erst nach dem
Appell. Dann gehe ich schauen.
* Drollige Klänge *
Also ...
Es sei heute ungünstig.
- Ja, okay.
Sie schreibt eine Mail,
wann es passen würde.
Gut, also.
- Ich kann nicht mehr machen.
Danke für deine Unterstützung.
- Kein Problem.
Okay, gut. Tschüss.
- Tschüss, Stefan, danke.
Was ist jetzt?
- Sie hat keine Zeit.
Und warum wohl?
Sie hat keine Zeit.
Wie ist das jetzt?
- Ja, das ist ...
... wie bestellt und nicht abgeholt.
Nächster Versuch.
Er sucht Jacqueline de Quattro,
neue FDP-Nationalrätin.
Die Mitteparteien
sind gespalten in der Klimafrage.
Hallo, Michi.
- Salut.
Herr Welti, hallo.
Christian Zeyer,
wir haben uns im Sommer gesehen.
Swisscleantech.
- Ja, genau.- Ah!
Ich versuche,
mit Frau de Quattro zu sprechen.
Sie ist vorhin vorbeigelaufen.
Darf ich rasch ...
- Wir müssen etwas erledigen.
* Drollige Klänge *
Ich muss einfach warten,
bis sie vorbeiläuft.
Dann muss ich sie anhalten.
CEO's 4 Climate?
- Du könntest auch unterschreiben.
Mit euren Bullshitwörtern
seid ihr immer noch gut.
Swisscleantech. Das ist gut.
Ihr müsst zu Rösti gehen.
* Drollige Klänge, Stimmengewirr *
Guten Tag, Frau de Quattro.
Danke für Ihre Zeit.- Sehr gerne.
Das ist das Projekt:
CEO's 4 Climate.
Die CEO's der Firmen haben gesagt:
"Wir finden es ein wichtiges Thema."
Die Reduktionsziele
müssen Paris-kompatibel sein,
also bis 2050 netto null.
Ich sehe, Sie haben grosse Partner.
Sie haben z.B. Implenia
oder Novartis.
Sie haben aber auch Start-ups.
Ich denke,
Sie haben einen guten Job gemacht,
indem Sie breit informieren,
glaubwürdig auftreten.
Wenn Sie sehen, dass das auch
von grossen Firmen unterstützt wird,
hilft Ihnen das bei der Entscheidung,
wenn Sie im März über das CO2-Gesetz
abstimmen müssen?- Ja, das hilft.
Sie können auf mich zählen,
ich mache gern mit.- Super, danke!
Ich lasse Ihnen das gern hier.
Wie grün aber
sind die CEO's 4 Climate?
Verpflichten sich die Firmen
mit ihrer Unterschrift,
das Klimaziel zu erreichen?
Nein, sagt er mir.
Bieten Sie den Firmen eine Plattform,
um Werbung für eine Sache zu machen,
von der Sie nicht garantieren können,
dass sie je erreicht wird?
Das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so.
Im Gegenteil.
Verschiedene Firmen haben sich aus
dieser Argumentation zurückgehalten.
Wir sind froh, dass wir mittlerweile
200 CEOs haben, die sagen:
"Ja, das wollen wir.
Das ist wichtig. Das macht man."
"Mit all den Herausforderungen
und den unangenehmen Fragen,
die von Journalisten
gestellt werden können."
Wie gerade jetzt.
- Genau.
Machen Sie sich als Verband auch
angreifbar?- Das nehmen wir in Kauf.
Die Aktion sei Mittel zum Zweck,
um das CO2-Gesetz durchzubringen.
In der Nähe des Zürcher Bahnhofs -
der Geschäftssitz von Swisscleantech.
350 Firmen sind Mitglied.
Fast 300-mal weniger
als beim Konkurrenten economiesuisse,
dessen Klimaziele
viel bescheidener sind.
Heute steht
dem promovierten Chemieingenieur
ein Gang in die Höhle des Löwen
bevor.
Die Reisebranche hat ihn
zu einem Vortrag eingeladen.
Briefing mit dem Pressesprecher.
In dem Saal bist du der Überbringer
von schlechten Botschaften.
In der griechischen Mythologie
ist es derjenige, der geköpft wurde.
Diese Rolle hast du dort inne.
Wichtig ist,
dass du nicht angriffig wirst.
Im Sinne von: "Ich bin wütend
auf alle, die Flugreisen promoten,
Kreuzfahrtreisen promoten,
nur damit sie Geld
verdienen können."
"Und wegen euch, wegen dir,
geht die Welt zugrunde."
Du musst positiv rüberkommen.
Die sind gefangen in einem System.
*  Pulsierende Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Flugreisen überall
und Kreuzfahrtschiffe.
Beides CO2-Schleudern.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Christian Zeyer, Swisscleantech.
Freut mich, Susanne Koch.
Es gibt ja bei diesen Schiffen
schon das Thema der CO2-Emissionen,
Treibhausgase etc.
- Ja.
Wie gehen Sie damit um?
Über den CO2-Ausstoss
habe ich hier keine Informationen.
Keine Informationen?
- Nein.
Werden Sie ab und zu danach gefragt
oder ist das gar kein Thema
bei den Kunden?
Kaum eigentlich.
Aus Sicht des Klimas müsste er
ein Kreuzfahrtschiffverbot fordern.
Tut er aber nicht. Zu radikal.
Ich bin nicht Greta Thunberg
und ich will sie auch nicht sein.
Ich bin vielleicht
die Greta der Hoffnung -
wenn man es so sagen will.
Ich glaube an die Chance,
die wir haben.
Glaubt Greta Thunberg
nicht auch daran?
Ich glaube, sie hat sehr viel Angst,
was ich auch begreife. Und ...
* Schluchzen *
* Stimmengewirr im Hintergrund *
Ich habe selber zwei Kinder.
Und ...
Ich denke, dass es
eine schwierige Situation ist.
* Schluchzen *
Doktor Christian Zeyer.
* Applaus, triumphale Musik *
* Akzentuierte Schlagzeugakkorde *
Das hier ist the Gate of Mumbai.
So sieht Ihre touristische
Attraktion in 100 Jahren aus.
Was ist zu tun? Raten Sie
den Leuten, langsamer zu reisen,
länger und lokaler zu reisen.
Man versucht,
das Problem in der Schweiz zu lösen,
indem man eine Ticketabgabe
auf Flugtickets machen will.
Das finden Sie auch gut, nicht?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Die Luftfahrt ist per se
ein globales Gewerbe
und braucht deshalb aus unserer
Sicht auch globale Lösungen.
Wir sind keine NGO.
Wir sind am Ende
ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen.
Man kann auch nicht nur
an der CO2-Vermeidung
oder -Verhinderung arbeiten.
Wir engagieren uns
für Menschenrechte.
Wir engagieren uns alle für
Kinderschutz, für Arbeitsschutz,
für Müllvermeidung
und alle diese Themen.
Funktioniert der Klimawandel nicht,
haben wir Probleme
mit den Fluchtbewegungen -
das wird Sie direkt betreffen,
liebe Touristiker.
Wir haben Probleme
mit der Biodiversität,
das wird Sie direkt betreffen.
Ich wollte das Thema nicht klein-
reden.-Lassen wir's mal so stehen.
Vielen herzlichen Dank,
meine Damen, meine Herren.
* Applaus *
* Drollige Musik *
Gut.
Wir haben uns immer
knapp an der Grenze bewegt,
an der sie mich dann
zum Verweigerer abstempeln wollten.
Ich habe immer ...
Z.T. haben Sie ziemlich ...
Sie waren bissig.
- Ich meine Sie persönlich.
Ich? Ja, natürlich. Klar.
Ich war etwas angespannt.
* Drollige Klänge *
Wenn diese Herren
dort vorne stehen und sagen,
man müsse auch
die ökonomischen Realitäten sehen,
dann muss ich sagen,
dass sie vielleicht noch nicht
über die Risiken nachgedacht haben.
Man nennt das stranded assets.
Wenn die
wie wild Flugzeuge bestellen
und die Klimapolitik
sich durchsetzt
und wir weniger fliegen -
als Hypothese -
sind das alles stranded assets.
Stranded assets -
Anlagen, die ihren Wert verlieren,
wenn der CO2-Preis stark erhöht wird.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
Sie sind ein Überzeugungstäter.
Täter vielleicht nicht,
aber überzeugt. Ja.
Der 58-Jährige lebt in Ostermundigen.
Seine zwei Kinder sind ausgezogen.
An manchen Wochenenden aber
trifft man sich zum Sport.
Tochter Flavia ist 23
und angehende Lehrerin.
Hoi, hoi.
Silvan ist 22.
Beruflich eifert er
seinem Vater nach,
studiert Energie- und Umwelttechnik.
* Leichte Trommelmusik *
Ich bin keiner,
der das Risiko sucht.
Ich bin einer,
der sehr vorsichtig klettert.
(Flavia)
Klippen nicht vergessen.
Wie?- Klippen nicht vergessen.
-Danke.
Natürlich würden sie an Klimastreiks
gehen, sagen Flavia und Silvan.
Die ganze Familie
engagiert sich umweltpolitisch.
Darf ich fragen?
Möchtet ihr mal Kinder?
Ja, natürlich.
Man muss nicht komplett
schwarzmalen und sagen,
es hätte alles keinen Sinn mehr.
Also, sorry,
was wollen wir noch machen?
Ich kann mich
im Zimmer einschliessen
und nicht mehr rauskommen.
Aber das ist auch keine Lösung.
Für mich ist es
kein einfaches Thema.
Weil ... ich ... ja ...
Ich frage mich, wie viel Verantwort-
ung wir als Generation vor euch
übernehmen müssen
- (Lachend) Dazu haben wir euch.
Das ist so Klartext.
Und, ähm ...
Das ist für mich schon schwierig.
Hast du Schuldgefühle
für deine Generation?- Ja.
Du hast dich nicht zurückgelehnt
und nichts gemacht.
Ja, aber ich habe 30 Jahre
nichts erreicht.
Erst seit ihr auf die Strasse geht,
bewegt sich etwas.
Heute sind sie seine Hoffnungsträger.
Früher aber tat sich
Christian Zeyer schwer
mit dem Thema Familienplanung.
Spielte das Klima bei der Überlegung,
Kinder zu haben oder nicht,
eine Rolle?
Ja, natürlich. Die Umweltfragen
spielten eine Rolle.
Das war für mich keine einfache
Entscheidung, das ist so.
Da hatten wir Glück!
Ich auch!
Vor zehn Jahren
sanierte er sein Haus,
damals eines der modernsten
im Umweltbereich.
Ich würde sagen, dass es heute
kein Vorzeigehaus mehr ist.
Vieles, was wir damals machten
und einen Wow-Effekt auslöste,
ist heute Standard.
Damals arbeitete er
als Energieberater.
Interessenten führte er
durch sein Vorzeigeheim
und kam so zu neuen Aufträgen.
Duschen mit solarerwärmtem Wasser -
das ist etwas Zusätzliches.
Das ist nicht nur Geld,
das sind auch Gefühle.
Es lohnt sich ...
Ökonomen und Energieexperten sagen,
es sei komplett naiv,
wenn Leute sagen - Sie auch - man
könne bis 2050 aus dem Öl aussteigen.
Öl sei der wichtigste Energieträger
der Welt
und werde dies
noch 40-50 Jahre bleiben.
Schwellenländer brauchen Öl,
der ganze Transport hängt vom Öl ab.
Mit solchen Aussagen streue man
den Leuten Sand in die Augen.
Dann lasse ich das mal so stehen.
Es gibt genügend andere Ökonomen
und Energieexperten,
die etwas anderes sagen.
Man wird sehen, was passiert.
Die Weltwirtschaft bricht ohne Öl
nicht zusammen?- Nein.
Aber von heute auf morgen
sei der Ausstieg schon nicht möglich.
Seine Frau ist Co-Teamleiterin
bei der Spitex.
Das Paar politisiert für die SP
im Gemeinderat.
Öko-Haushalt -
hätten Schulkollegen früher gesagt.
Ich weiss noch,
wie es dich immer nervte ...
Papi ging immer oder viel joggen.
Und du hattest nie so
Fancy-Sportkleider.
Du hast oft die gebrauchten Kleider
angezogen, um joggen zu gehen.
Da sagte Flavia einmal,
es sei ein No-Go,
du könntest nicht am Schulhaus vor-
beijoggen, wenn die Schule aus sei,
das sei so was von peinlich.
* Jazzige Klänge, Stimmengewirr *
Ich glaube, das ist gut.
Schön, seid Ihr da!
Ich habe einen neuen Anzug gekauft
und mich schick gemacht.
Du siehst hübsch aus.
Zehn Jahre - das gibt es
nicht so oft, nur alle zehn Jahre.
Ich gehe irgendwann wieder.
- Ja, das ist klar.
Dass er seine Überzeugung lebt,
weiss ich unterdessen.
Dass er bei Swisscleantech
auch schwierige Zeiten durchmachte,
erfahre ich am zehnjährigen Jubiläum.
Santé!
Sein Verhältnis zum Gründer
ist gespalten:
Nick Beglinger
verliess den Verband vor vier Jahren.
Er galt als Enfant terrible.
Er war eher pushy unterwegs.
Ich fand dann jeweils,
er könne nicht so Gas geben.
Und er erwiderte,
wenn wir nicht Gas geben würden,
kämen wir nicht weiter.
Da haben wir uns z.T.
schon heftig gestritten.- Ja.
Hatte das auch einen Nachteil? Ihre
pushy Art ist nicht schweizerisch.
Absolut! Wie ich es vorhin gesagt
habe, gab es viele Firmen,
die sagten, solange ich Präsident
sei, kämen sie nicht zu uns.
Das ist heavy,
wenn einem das gesagt wird -
vom Verband, den man
mit dem eigenen Geld gegründet hat.
Vielen Dank!
Er hat es geboren
und ich habe es aufgezogen.
In Schmerzen.
Wir hatten keinen Vertrag
miteinander.- Nein.
Das lief auf Mandatsbasis,
unbezahlt.
Irgendwann habe ich
eine Rechnung geschrieben
und die wurde nicht bezahlt.
- Genau.
Die ist einfach liegengeblieben.
Nach wie vielen Jahren
hat es einen Lohn gegeben?
Wann war das? 20...
2014, oder? Keine Ahnung,
ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Vier, fünf Jahre.
2013. Irgendwann dann.
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Sie sind ein extremer Idealist.
Ja.
Jetzt bist du nicht mehr
in einer Trotzphase.
Wir sind in der meinungsmachenden
Mitte angelangt - extrem wichtig.
Aber mit 350 Firmen hätten sie
immer noch zu wenig Mitglieder.
Auch wenn der pushy Mann weg ist ...
- Es ist eine Realität.
... hat es keinen Firmenzuwachs
gegeben.
Es ist ein Thema, das nach wie vor
nicht enorm beliebt ist.
Das ist ganz klar.
Wir stossen an Herausforderungen.
Also ...
Ich denke ... Wir argumentieren
vor der falschen Person.
Ich appelliere an Schweizer Firmen:
Sie sollen Mitglied werden
bei Swisscleantech.
Liebe Schweizer Firmen,
es ist höchste Zeit,
Mitglied bei Swisscleantech
zu werden!
How dare you not to be!
Greta sagt es für die Welt,
ich sage es für die Schweiz.
Jetzt pusht er wieder.
Jetzt haben Sie wieder Angst, dass er
dem Verband schadet?- Genau!
Angst nicht, ich habe - sorry -
aber ich habe etwas Mühe
mit dem Stil.- Das verstehe ich.
Wie aber sieht die finanzielle
Zukunft des Verbandes aus?
Das meiste Geld kommt von Stiftungen.
Im Moment haben wir
einen Vierjahresvertrag,
der jetzt ausläuft.
Wir sind am Diskutieren,
wie es weitergeht.
Dieses Jahr?
- Ja.
Beim zehnjährigen Jubiläum?
Und kann es sein,
dass die nicht mehr zahlen?
Es kann sein, dass die Stiftungen
nicht mehr bezahlen.
Das ist denkbar. Das gibt es.
Wie viele Personen müssten gehen?
- Ich müsste halbieren.
Ja.
Das ist happig.
- Ja, natürlich, das ist klar.
In einem glücklichen Moment,
in einem Jubiläum,
ist Ihnen gleichzeitig bewusst,
dass vieles auf dem Spiel steht.
Ja, natürlich.
Zehnmal mehr Mitglieder bräuchte der
Verband, um selbsttragend zu sein.
Die Kehrseite des grünen Tsunami.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Woher aber rührt es, das bedingungs-
lose Engagement des 58-Jährigen?
Aufgewachsen ist er in Luzern,
seine Mutter habe ihn stark geprägt.
Hallo.
* Er lacht. *
Hast du Gipfeli dabei?
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Yvonne Zeyer, stolze 90 Jahre alt.
Früher war sie Ärztin.
Sie unterrichtete auch an Schulen
zum Thema Umwelt und Gesundheit.
In den 1960er-Jahren
war sie alarmiert.
(Original) Jährlich krepieren in
unseren Gewässern Tausende Fische.
Zu Hunderten münden Abwassergräben
und Kloaken in den See.
(Yvonne) Da wurde diskutiert ...
... dass es mit dem Wasser
schlecht läuft.
Dazu kam der Konsumismus,
der sich breitmachte.
Das war Ende der 50er-,
Anfang der 60er-Jahre.
Der war absurd.
Vonseiten der Wissenschaft wurden
da grosse Fragezeichen gemacht.
Und die haben das -
und das fasziniert mich so -
sie haben das so vorausgesagt -
wie es jetzt ist.
Finden Sie?
Dann kam der Katalysator,
Phosphate wurden verboten.
Es ist auch sehr viel Gutes passiert.
Das ist das, was eindrücklich ist.
Immer wenn etwas gemacht wurde,
ist auch etwas passiert.
Aber man hat viel nicht gemacht.
Das ist der Witz.
Man muss sagen ...
Sehr viele der Geschichten,
die gemacht wurden, wurden geflickt,
indem man noch mehr Energie
reingebuttert hat.
Eine Kläranlage z.B.
braucht relativ viel Energie.
Der zehnjährige Christian
bat seinen Lehrer,
einen Vortrag halten zu dürfen.
Titel: "Unser Land ist in Gefahr".
"Es kann sein, dass wir in 20 Jahren
nur noch mit der Gasmaske
in die Stadt gehen können."
"Die Ölheizungen, Autos, Töffli und
Fabriken verbrauchen unsere Luft
und verpesten sie."
Er hatte wirklich Angst -
offensichtlich.
Aber ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Ich habe das als Interesse
interpretiert.
Hat sich Ihre Besorgnis
auf ihn übertragen?
Ich glaube es schon.
Wenn ich den Vortrag lese,
denke ich: "Da ist viel Mama drin."
Irgendwo ...
Manchmal habe ich auch
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Leben Sie noch gern in dieser Welt?
Ja ...
Das finde ich
eine sehr schwierige Frage.
Als Flavia und Silvan auf die Welt
gekommen sind, habe ich geweint.
Ich hatte keine Grossmutterfreuden,
weil ich wusste,
was auf sie zukommt, so oder so.
Das ist klar. Das ist, das ist ...
Und darum sage ich,
dass es das Schlimmste ist,
was ich in meinem Leben erlebt habe.
- Ja.
... was wir gemacht haben. Wirklich.
Zwei Monate später. Sonntagabend:
Hallo, Fabian.
Salü, Christian.
- Hoi.
Danke, dass du Zeit hast,
die paar Dinge zu besprechen.
Der Verband scheint vorerst gerettet:
Eine Stiftung hat 1 Mio.
in Aussicht gestellt -
aber nur unter klaren Auflagen.
Absprache mit seinem Vizepräsidenten
von der FDP:
2021 muss das Ziel sein, dass wir
gerade im Segment der Grossfirmen
noch einmal
ein substanzielles Wachstum haben.
Was heisst das in Zahlen?
20 wäre für mich
ein realistisches Ziel.
* Schleppende Musik *
Es ist eine anstrengende Situation,
auf jeden Fall.
Manchmal bin ich müde.
Wenn es mir völlig
zu viel werden würde,
dann könnte ich mir auch vorstel-
len, etwas Handwerkliches zu machen.
Ein kleiner Lieferwagen -
ausgebaut mit einer Werkstatt
und dann Dinge reparieren -
das wäre cool.
Aber das steht im Moment
wirklich nicht im Fokus für mich.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass wir eine
nachhaltige Wirtschaft brauchen.
Dafür will ich mich einsetzen,
das ist ganz klar.
Also noch lange nicht genug?
- Nein, noch nicht genug.
Sicher nicht.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020